country superstar eric church has
majorly upset his massive fan base the
church choir after making what he admits
is the quote most selfish decision oh he
said it okay yeah fans are in an uproar
after eric canceled a huge concert in
san antonio so he can
cheer on his team university of north
carolina as they face their massive
rival duke in the highly anticipated
ncaa final four this weekend in a letter
sent to ticket holders eric writes this
this saturday my family and i are going
to stand together and cheer on the tar
heels as
as the team has made it to the final
four as a lifelong carolina basketball
fan i've watched carolina and duke
battle it out or battle it over the
years but half uh have them match up in
the final four for the first time in the
history of the ncaa tournament is any
sports enthusiast dream
and the singer continued this is also
the most selfish thing i've ever asked
the choir to do
to give up your saturday night plans
with us so that i can have this moment
with my family and sports community
however it's that same type of passion
felt by the people who fill the seats at
our concerts that makes us want to be
part of a crowd at a game of this
significance
oh my goodness me so as you can imagine
this announcement has brought on a lot
of reaction from fans with lots making
it known they spend their hard-earned
money on concert tickets now one twitter
user said this even if they get refunded
for their tickets people have still
booked fairs places to stay and probably
time off work to watch him i understand
the want of being there in person
but it's not a reason to screw over your
fans yeah meanwhile one diehard fan
comes to eric's defense writing i have
zero problem with this eric church is
simply exhibiting the same passion that
we show for him and our own favorite
things
i have have you ever taken off work to
do something you enjoy then you made the
same call i'm positive he will make it
up to fans in texas at some point now
it's also important to point out the
concert was cancelled rather than
postponed so what are your thoughts on
all of this do you give him credit for
being you know admitting this what he
calls selfishness or how should eric
make it up to his fans what are people
saying well we got um carla says his
fans have a right to be upset many fans
plan ahead of time flying in taking time
off etc bean says
ouch and i'm feeling that i feel i feel
the same way like i would not be very
happy if i were a fan of this guy and
like he said hey listen i'm cancelling
my show because i'm gonna go do
um go to watch something else that you
guys also aren't gonna have access to
like
yeah that's kind of that's not good like
i don't that the one comment about hey
listen have you ever taken time off work
to go do a thing that you've done very
different very different lots and lots
of people have put in some money are
taking time off work thousands of people
to go do this thing and just gonna be
like yeah peace
uh like when you get an explanation that
long sometimes that's all you really
need to know you're like here's here's
words that are trying to to make up for
this thing that the person knows is like
not a great thing to do no and i mean
trying to make it seem like you guys
understand you guys understand it it's
just screams to me not very self aware
of how you make other people feel not
that you have to be responsible for
everybody's happiness but when you are
holding a concert to make everyone happy
and to bring entertainment and you book
that i can you know there's health
issues and there's other things that
come when concerts have to be cancelled
but when it's to what you could pvr it
and get people to not tell you all
around
right
now i mean now the other argument here
is
saying well he could have just said he
could have made up an excuse
to cancel it what would have been what
would have been better that i'm sorry
but i said what no one else will say
you know that if he said i'm really sick
or uh the weather was bad
ooh hope you get better i hope you get
better but then if you've seen it at the
thing after
well yeah i know you're right he
couldn't say that yeah i don't know i
just again feel bad for all the fans who
spent their money and took time off work
got babysitters made a weekend of it or
whatever that's hard i don't know for
some people i've been in my house for
two years this is my first big forum
totally never thought
like i am the number one fan of this
person i'm going to see my friends it
but he's gonna go watch the you know the
tar heels i guess